sur un dernier mot sur les les
États-Unis parce que Anthony blinen
était en tourné dans la région c'est
quelques jours le secrétaire d'État
américain notamment pour faire pression
sur Israël pour protéger les civils
palestiniens est-ce qu'il a les moyens
de faire pression là-dessus s'il y a la
volonté il y a les moyens sauf que les
Américains ne sont pas très crédibles
par rapport à Israël il lui passent tous
les caprice euh ils sont plus crédibles
par rapport aux Arabes parce que ils ont
beaucoup reculer rappelez-vous la
Somalie rappelez-vous Beyrouth en 83 ils
se sont retirés la France aussi après
avoir subi de lourdes pertes
rappelez-vous plus récemment l'échec de
la guerre en Irak l'échec de de de de du
conflit en Afghanistan et surtout le
retrait humiliant de l'armée américaine
d'Afghanistan ça fait 2 ans que ça s'est
passé donc tout ça fait que les
Américains n'ont plus la crédibilité ni
auprès d'Israël qui les mène par le bout
du nez ni auprès des arabes qui ont bien
compris qu'ils ne seront jamais la
puissance les Américains sont sur le
retrait dans cette région du monde ils
n'ont pas envie de se défendre
d'ailleurs à une certaine époque les
États-Unis se s'approvisionner en
pétrole de la région aujourd'hui les
États-Unis sont le premier exportateur
de pétrole grâce au au pétrole et gaz de
schiste donc de ce fait ils se sont ils
se sentent beaucoup beaucoup plus indép
par rapport à la région leur centre
d'intérêt était la Chine l'Asie puis
avec la guerre en Ukraine de contenir la
poussée russe maintenant ce conflit qui
arrive réveille un peu les Américains
mais ils n'ont pas la crédibilité pour
être respecté en Israël et craindre dans
les pays arabes
juste